the most important thing is for us to
keep our eye on her breathing okay we
have to make sure that she continues to
breathe normally
you there yeah i'm listening i'm
listening to her breathing
tamar braxton is recovering after being
hospitalized
now her boyfriend david adefaso is
opening up about the 43 year old
struggles with
mental health and is thanking the public
for their thoughts and
prayers in a statement david calls tamar
a beautifully talented woman
a devoted mother a loving girlfriend a
dear sister
and a special friend to countless people
adding quote
this is an extremely difficult time for
tamar and her family as she navigates
professional
and personal struggles including her
battle with depression
david added that she's receiving the
best possible medical attention to
address those struggles
and asked for fans to pray for her path
to recovery and
ultimate happiness what's your emergency
my girlfriend is not responding are you
with her right now
yes the braxton family values star was
found
unresponsive on july 17 by her boyfriend
at the ritz-carlton residences in los
angeles
where they were staying like i said
we're on the way
um i'm gonna stay on the line okay she's
been drinking
it's like a halfway uh she's on
medication for depression i don't know
how much
she sent a letter earlier anyway just
ask him to hurry
the los angeles police department told
et that they received a call around 9 45
p.m regarding a medical emergency adding
that an individual was transported to
the hospital
a spokesperson for the los angeles fire
department
also informed et that they responded to
a call for a reported
unconscious adult female at the time the
blast reported tamar was
in stable condition but still
unconscious
and under 24 hour watch at the hospital
now the blast is reporting that tamar is
awake and
alert talking to doctors about the days
leading up to her hospitalization
tamar is now getting the proper help
that she needs
on saturday real housewives of atlanta
star nene leakes took to instagram live
to give fans an
update on her friend with tamar
tamar and myself we have been dealing
with
a lot of different issues
and i was trying to be her support
system
and she was being my support system
she has been hurting and um
and and we've all dealt with a lot of
stuff lately just
dealt with a really really tremendous
amount of
stress it just goes to show you how
resilient we all are when we have to
figure it out
we figure it out in may the crazy kind
of love singer reflected on her fighting
spirit i'm one of those women just like
all the women in america that i run into
is that you know we never give up
we do whatever it takes especially when
you're thrown into the position where
you're a single mom
it's like everything is hard but nothing
is too hard
tamar shared that she'd been
quarantining in los angeles with david
and her seven-year-old son logan whom
she shares with her ex-husband
vincent herbert she gushed that all this
quality time with her beau
proved he really is the one we really
have gotten
closer to be honest um we've had a
chance to talk about things
um that we wouldn't normally have time
to talk about and
see things that we normally wouldn't see
because we haven't spent this much time
together
and i have to say he's not just
chocolate he's a great guy